he's a large fella how they call him the
cuban missle now
now remember Pittman Nolan Ryan good
picture we're rolling right Marinol look
like Clint Eastwood yeah
now try hitting off the Cuban missile
look on the far right the vco el Romero
look like a high schooler I think he
throws like a hundred for something
crazy
Oh uol's on his page yeah he's pitch for
the Yankees okay yeah well he's enormous
now he's six I don't know six eight or
some [ __ ] like there's all the six
Skeets imagine trying to hit that ball I
mean for me if I can see if I can see
the does six four just like the 212 that
this looks huge though he's so big yeah
I think he's bigger than 212 his arms
our legs so I think he's more than that
hey you always find out you're like how
much - forty I can guarantee he's bigger
than 212
well they got on the left has Malik legs
yeah little juice you're that five where
is that the guy on the right is the guy
on the right needs to get a bike and
join the big boy bike club that's a big
guy but for a pitcher dude I'm pretty
sure he feels like 104 you got to start
swinging the minute it leaves his hand
Brennan that's what I've always said
sort of my life what that's the best
pitch ever recorded oh my god is there a
video of that that's [ __ ] nuts buddy
hit it well we did in Arizona we were
gonna stand in front of that the guy who
pitches a hundred I wasn't gonna do that
remember I don't want to do that I'm
afraid of it me too I'm afraid of all
things baseball forget him
let's just him warming up here goes 99
I get Pedro Alvares who's fun done this
a thousand times doesn't seem very yeah
Oh 100 miles an hour this I miss
baseball ja dude still get his batter
before getting his bat around on that
hundred for truth is there a net there
yeah oh oh look crazy
105 that looks these guys are not afraid
of the fall he was trying to do is get
that hundred five huh oh he had a home
Ralph of him okay well that oh no you
know what 105 looks the same as 90 to me
yeah it does that's 104 dude he's
throwing as we call it in the in the big
leaf gasps gasps oh my gasps and he's
got a tail piece on well it looks like
your speed doesn't it sure that a little
bit like OSB yep 105 God a hundred if I
broke the battery don't remember Randy
Johnson yeah when he kicked that bird
yup yup 611 leave it oh he's you're
crazy you think he's 212 yeah you're
crazy if you think it's 212 you're crazy
he's built like an ostrich she's got the
biggest butt I've ever seen so you have
an ostrich in your shorts sir that
options blame baseball yeah you have it
you have a muscular ostrich now is he
playing baseball booty pitches for the
pay look at that look at the power of
this team in the world yeah
oh here we go Jesus rice oh my let me
see if I can do this [ __ ] I don't think
we could I can barely get my battery
over 6 out of this no you're not getting
your bat around in time how's that guys
not how hard is this guy in the catches
he's not wearing any
he's probably Pro too though I would
imagine he's a professional I can't just
be your boy catch a home right now no
what's going on with his class does he
have three cups on Casey misses Jesus
right strike I don't see it like and and
Kevin told me that when his guy pitches
100% he'll never hit me no their
controls insane you kidding me their
control is insane but it's possible they
can hit
that's what I always say maybe but they
can still hit you like in the [ __ ]
thigh scary not cool though yes and
maybe a six Honda or six for boys making
money though mmm-hmm it's pretty cool
huh
hopefully baseball comes back I think
it's any better just they do a 60 game
season right it's what baseball needs
cuz they usually play 182 games so no
one's watching all those games you 60
games it's kinda like turns the NFL
because then every game is important
every guy's trying the pitcher is gonna
get rest they're gonna be able to pitch
you're gonna get key players playing
longer
it's got no cabs not in that the
smallest cast not in that picture
they're pretty small and and well I have
to believe that that picture wasn't
doctored to make his cab small outfit
though look thin there cuz the white
stripes on the side I think his calves
are mi I don't think ears pitch 106 now
and you see a lot of guys who are super
fast and super athletic we don't have
calves oh yeah he has Malik keV he's got
Miley calves and he's tatted to the
gills he looks like the game he looks
cool and that outfit that shirt is just
don't know know where I come from I'd
say - no no yeah you know who can only
wear those shirts the Cuban Missile and
campaigns that's rather than that don't
wear this cam wear those told not to
he's cool he's roughly my age he's back
he's hunting and I tell not to yeah let
me see yeah maybe on his Instagram
yeah isn't done in a while maybe stop
maybe listen to us there it is yeah
that's what he rocks it's that's kind of
okay that's still hmm it's not so no no
for me but it's not but the audience can
do whatever the hell you want the Cuban
missiles wearing a different shirt
go back to the commune is those agencies
nipples cuz that's right I cut something
guys if I see your tits yeah you're
you're cutting you're not why we're a
shirt don't show me nipples I think the
rule is can't see your nips no nips yeah
that's an issue what else
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]